The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So as I was
saying, what we want to do
is get up through use of some of
these statistical distributions
for making hypotheses tests and
understanding the relationship
of probabilities associated
with hypotheses such as a point
belongs to this distribution
or that distribution.
And that will set the
ground for talking
about statistical process
control and SPC charting, where
you're asking the question
of a new piece of data
off of the manufacturing
line, does that piece of data
come from the in
control distribution?
Or does it come from some
out of control distribution?
So it's all about
probabilities on SPC charts.
And we want to build up
the rest of the machinery
that we need for that today.
To do that, one of
the subtle things
that we have to understand
a bit more about
is sampling and
sampling distributions.
And really what we're
dealing with here
is issues of the
use of statistics
dealing with observed data.
And I have this
philosophical picture
of what I think of as
statistics meaning.
And that's our real goal and
statistics is to reason about,
think about, and be able
to argue about processes--
in our case, real
manufacturing processes--
when there's uncertainty
in those processes.
There is noise.
There's other things
we don't know.
But the key idea
in statistics is
we are getting some evidence.
We're getting some data.
And what we want
to be able to do
is use that data to start
to infer things back
about the underlying
population, the underlying
process or distribution.
So there are some
preconditions in here.
A lot of what I said here
is we're reasoning based
on evidence from observed data.
But that really means we
are taking fundamentally
a probability model
of what's going on.
And we talked last
time, for example,
about assumptions with normal
distributions and parameters
of normal distributions.
And what we're going to do
today is focus a little bit more
on evidence coming from
finite sets of observations,
drawn from that population,
and then calculations we
do on that--
simple calculations, like
calculating the sample mean.
And then we have this
number, this sample mean.
What's it really telling us?
What can we infer back about
the underlying distribution--
what the true mean of the
underlying population is?
And then a little bit later,
we'll flesh this out more.
But already, even as we start
building these simple arguments
based on our data, we have
an underlying implicit model
of the process.
It may be a purely
probabilistic model,
saying it has a certain mean
and a Gaussian distribution
or a certain mean in a normal--
or a uniform or a Poisson.
There is a model there.
And so we have to keep in
mind that it is only a model.
A little bit later,
we'll also build up
other kinds of
functional relationships
when we get to things like
response surface modeling.
But for now, these are
relatively simple models,
mostly focused on the
probabilistic or stochastic
nature of that.
So here's the plan for today.
What we're going to do
is talk a little bit
about sampling distributions.
We touched on this a
little bit last time
when we talked about
the distribution
of the sum of random variables
and the central limit theorem,
where the sum or
the average always
tends towards the normal.
In some of the cases, we're
going to be calculating things,
like the sample s
squared, the sample
variants that are not going
to be normally distributed.
They will have other
statistical shapes
or statistical distributions
such as the chi-squared.
There will be other cases where
the student t-distribution is
operable.
So we want to get a sense of
these sampling distributions
and understand how to use
those to make not only point
estimates--
that is our best guess of things
like the underlying population
mean--
but also confidence intervals--
where, with some probability,
we think the true mean lies or
we think the true
variance lies based
on one set of observations.
So that's where the sampling
distributions come into play.
And we'll talk about the
effects of sample size on that
as well as things like
what kind of inferences,
these point and confidence
interval inferences
we can make on those.
And then, again, leading up
towards hypothesis testing.
And then really, this
will be for next time.
We'll dive into SPC charts.
So here's how we typically
are using sampling.
We have some underlying--
I'll refer to it as the
population distribution
or sometimes the
parent distribution.
It's the set or universe
of all possible parts,
say, coming off your
manufacturing line
or all possible observations.
What we're typically
going to do is just draw
some number, some finite
number, of samples,
some n samples of
the process output--
so some x sub i drawn
from a parent distribution
with some PDF p.
And what we're going to
be doing is calculating
these sample mean, sample
variants, other sorts
of sample statistics.
A key point here is
the underlying process.
That basic variable x has
a probability distribution
function associated with it.
This new variable x
bar that we calculate,
this statistic
that we calculate,
also has a probability density
function associated with it.
And it's a different
one than the parent one.
And so what we'll
need to understand
is what those
probability distributions
are that arise from
sampling, and then
how to work backwards from
those to make inferences
about the parent.
Now, a quick thing.
I guess there's both
definitions on this slide,
but also a quick thing about
definitions or terminology
or notation that I like to use.
And in particular, I'm,
again, distinguishing
between the population or
parent distribution, and then
these sample statistics.
And typically when I talk
about "truth" or the population
as a whole, we're
using Greek variables
like mu, sigma, rho, xy, for
the correlation coefficient.
And those expectations,
those different moments,
are calculated over
the entire population.
Typically we're doing
those analytically
if we have a closed
form description of what
the population is.
In contrast, I'm
going to typically use
Roman characters--
x, s, r, xy, for example--
to indicate the finite
sample statistics
calculated from some n
number of observations.
And so that's when we have
a finite discrete number
of observations.
And we have simple formulas
for the calculation
of those statistics.
A little bit later
in the term, we
will come back and start to
look in particular at covariance
and correlation between two
different random variables,
some x and y.
Those are especially
important when we're looking
for functional dependencies.
Right now, we're simply
looking at one set of data
or one population,
one random variable x.
So we'll focus on
univariate stuff today.
There is a term,
"random sampling,"
that actually has a
technical definition that I
want to point out that's very
close to the intuitive notion
here.
But it actually is a
little bit stronger
in requirements
for its definition.
We said sampling is this act of
taking some finite observations
out of a population.
Random sampling is when every
observation that we pull
is identically distributed,
has the same PDF associated
with it, and is independent
from any other sample that we
pull from that population.
And this would not always
naturally be the case--
if you had, for example,
finite populations,
and you pulled out a sample,
held it in your hand,
recorded it, pulled out
another sample, for example.
Imagine that you've got a bag of
17 blue and red marbles in it.
And I pull a marble
out, and it's red.
I hold it in my hand, and
I pull another marble out.
Do you think I'm sampling
from the same underlying
distribution?
No, because I did not
replace that original marble.
So now the mix of
blue and red marbles
is different within that
bag, and the probability
is different.
It is not identical and
independent anymore.
The observation that I made
first, based on the first draw,
changes the probability
for later draws, changes--
there is dependence
as well as no longer
an identical distribution.
So when we do random sampling,
as I'm defining it here,
and random sampling
for calculation
of some of these
sampling distributions,
we're assuming if it's coming
from a finite population,
you would always put
the observation back in
and do another sample
from the same pool.
Typically what
you're often doing
is assuming there's
no connection from one
to the other, and the
same process, physics,
is operable from one
point in time to the next.
So we are typically making
this IID, this Independent
and Identically
Distributed assumption.
And then we're going to,
again, as I said, calculate
some statistics from those.
Ultimately, when
you have a sample--
sample of size 14, drawn
from a big population.
You calculate x bar.
What do you get?
A number.
You get an actual number
because I observed those 14
things, measured length
or whatever it was
that I was measuring on those.
And so a key point here
is that the statistic
is a function of the
sample and the sample data.
And so it's actually a
value that you can compute.
If I do that, I grab one
sample, I calculate that x bar,
I've got one number.
If I were to go back
and draw another sample
from that distribution,
I get a different number.
And so if I keep
going back and drawing
multiple, multiple
samples, that's
how you build up a distribution
function associated
with that statistic,
that calculation.
So that's where this notion of
statistics, x bar or whatever,
as a random variable
also comes into play.
For any one sample
it's a number.
But when I go and take multiple
samples, multiple sets, of n,
now I build up a distribution
function associated with those.
I'm going to switch here to--
or do I want to?
No.
I'm going to switch to--
this is here on the web.
I mentioned last time
this very nice website.
I don't even know
what the acronym
stands for-- this SticiGui.
It's out of the Department
of Statistics at Berkeley.
It's got a lot of different--
I guess sort of an online
course kind of thing.
But what I really like
in this is the Tools tab.
So if I go to that Tools tab--
let me do that--
it's got a number of these
little Java utilities online.
And one that I want
to look at here first
is sampling distributions.
So let's see.
Let this load.
Loading up Java, here.
So here's an example
of sampling from some
a priori distribution.
And this is actually drawing
from a uniform distribution
with discrete values,
0, 1, 2, 3, and 4.
So that's our underlying
true population,
and they all have
equal probabilities.
And what I'm going to
do is calculate a--
I'm going to draw a sample
down here at the bottom.
It's a sample of size 5.
So I'm going to do random
sampling with replacement.
So I'm going to draw five
independent and identically
distributed samples out of that
underlying parent distribution.
And then I'm going to
calculate some statistic.
What I want to do is to actually
calculate the sample mean.
So there in blue is our
underlying population.
Let me take one sample of
size 5, calculate the mean,
and plot it.
There it is.
It's a mean of 1.4.
Let me take another sample.
I take another sample.
Do you think the value
is going to be 1.4 again?
It might be.
AUDIENCE: Might be.
PROFESSOR: But
probably not, right?
Let's see what happens.
There it is-- 2.4.
Let me do a few more.
So the green bars
are popping up,
as I think I've done something
like 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6--
something like 8 different
samples, each of size 5,
plotted the mean.
Now to speed things
up, I can keep
taking more and more samples.
What distribution do you
think this is trending to?
AUDIENCE: Normal.
PROFESSOR: Normal.
Down here at the bottom,
I can take samples
that are a little bit larger.
Or let me take--
excuse me, we take--
the thing tells me
how many samples I'm taking,
so I don't have to just take
one sample of five, plot it.
I can take 10 samples of
5, each of 5, and plot it.
So it's just speeding
up my button clicks
so that we can get a little
bit better shape on that.
So there's the point.
That's a very fascinating point.
I find it fascinating
that I can sample
from a non-normal
distribution, take the average,
the sample average, x bar, and
over lots and lots of sampling,
I get a normal distribution.
What else?
What other observations
or what other points
might you make about
that green distribution?
What do you think is true
about that green distribution?
There's a really
important fact which
motivates why we can't
calculate x bars all the time
and believe the
numbers that come out
of an x bar calculation.
AUDIENCE: It's
centered around 2.
PROFESSOR: It's
Out of the numbers
0, 1, 2, 3, and 4,
what do you think the average
is-- the true average?
2.
So one thing that's very
nice about the sample mean
is that it trends toward
the true population mean.
It's unbiased.
That if I were to
take enough samples,
the average of or the mean of
all of these sample averages
is equal to the true
underlying population mean.
It's unbiased.
Doesn't have a bias or
delta, a fixed delta,
a fixed offset error in it.
It is an unbiased estimator.
So I can take lots
and build that up.
Turns out there's
another thing that's
true which I don't
want to go into
and don't want to try to prove.
But it turns out that the sample
mean is also not only unbiased,
but it's also the
minimum error estimator.
So on average, it's the
best estimator of the mean
that you can use as a statistic,
meaning its distribution
in some sense is the narrowest.
The x bar distribution is
the narrowest estimator
you can have for trying to
calculate the sample mean
based on your distributions.
Now another important
thing that comes up
here is at least a
few of the times,
I got a sample
mean that was 0.6.
Is it wrong?
If you do just one sample,
it's quite possible,
out of this set of four,
I drew a sample of size 5.
I might have gotten
a value of 0.6.
That's all the data you have.
What's your best guess
for the true mean
of the underlying population?
That 0.6, whatever
that value was.
But now there is
some spread on it.
And so if you're
wise, you would also
start to want to hedge your
bets a little bit here, right?
You want to be able to
say, my best guess is 0.5.
But I think I'm only
drawing a sample of size 5.
So I know there is, in fact,
this kind of Gaussian spread.
And I think the
true mean probably
lies within some range of that.
And so you would like to have
this confidence interval idea.
We'll get back to that
a little bit later.
In fact, there's another
very nice little tool in here
for illustrating
confidence intervals
that we'll use at that point.
I want to do one more
thing, and then we'll
go back to the lecture slides.
One of the neat things
you can do with this tool,
and it's lots of
fun for you guys
to connect up with
and play with,
is you can change
the sample size.
Let's say you wanted a
better or a tighter estimate
for the x bar.
You're not happy
with the idea that
sometimes, with fairly
substantial probability,
you might be off
by plus or minus 1.
You have a substantial
probability
of estimating, say, the--
or guessing the sample mean
to be more than one value away
from the true population mean.
What might you do
to try to improve
your likelihood of being closer
to the true mean when you're
doing sampling?
AUDIENCE: More samples.
PROFESSOR: More samples.
More samples?
I guess you could
do more samples.
But in some sense, really, that
taking one sample of size 5
and another sample
of size 5, that's
like one sample of size 10.
Larger samples.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah,
larger samples.
PROFESSOR: Larger samples.
So if I do that
here, let's take--
instead of samples of size
5, let's do a modest increase
first and take
samples of size 10.
See what happens now.
Oops, let me just do--
OK, that's good.
I'm taking a lot
of samples here.
I've taken several hundred
samples, each of size 10.
And sure enough,
that distribution
is a little bit tighter.
Let's say if I took a really
big sample, sample of size 100.
Yeah, looking a lot tighter.
So one question is, we know
as I take a larger samples,
the distribution gets tighter.
One of the things we
want to do is understand
how much tighter do they get as
a function of the sample size?
So it turns out-- let
me go back now to--
it turns out that if I'm
sampling from a parent
distribution, the variance in
the estimate of that x bar,
or the PDF, the variance
of x bar itself,
shrinks with size n.
And the variance in
fact scales as 1 over n.
It scales inversely proportional
to the size of the sample.
That's true always as you take
larger numbers of samples.
For this special case, if
my underlying population
is in fact really a true--
has a true probability
distribution function
that was normal,
then it turns out
that x bar is not just
trending towards the normal,
but is itself, even for very
small numbers of samples, also
a normal distribution.
So in that little
demo I showed you,
drawing from a
uniform distribution,
for large enough n's,
large enough samples,
large enough numbers
of samples, the mean
does trend towards a Gaussian.
But it's even a stronger
statement, a stronger
relationship, if the underlying
population is itself normal.
So let's say we start with an
underlying random variable,
an underlying
process x, that has
some mean and some variance.
Now if I take samples of size 1
and plot out the distribution,
what do you think it looks like?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I'm just repeating.
I'm replicating my underlying
distribution, right?
So part of the special
case of a sample of size 1,
if I do that long enough, I
build up the same distribution.
But now, if I take larger
numbers of samples,
even a little bit
with n equals 2,
again, we get that
effect that we
saw with the SticiGui of the
narrowing of the distribution,
PDF associated with the x bar.
And in particular, the PDF or
the Probability Distribution
Function associated
with x bar is exactly
normal with the same mean--
it's unbiased-- and
with reduced variance.
So the variance
goes as 1 over n.
So we start with the
population distribution here,
and we end up with a
sample mean distribution
that is a different PDF.
Everybody clear on this?
So key points--
statistic itself is
the random variable has its
own probability distribution
function.
Now what we want to do is reason
about the underlying population
based on those
observed statistics.
Somebody's cell
phone is going crazy.
Not mine.
Everybody hear that click?
Can you even hear that
click in Singapore?
Yeah?
All right.
Hopefully that will
go away in a second.
So once we know the sampling
distribution, say, for x bar,
now we can argue about the
probabilities associated
with observing particular
values of x bar.
We can make observations
or arguments
about how much probability's out
in the tails of these things.
And then we can invert
backwards and reason
about the actual
population mean.
And again, we're after
not only the point
estimates, our best guess,
but also interval estimates--
confidence intervals where
we think the actual value
is going to lie.
And these are critically
dependent on probability
calculations of the
sampling distribution.
So here's an example.
So suppose that we start
out with some assumptions.
We start out with some a priori
beliefs about the distribution
of some parameter.
In particular, we're interested
in the thickness of some part.
We don't know the mean of it.
But based on maybe lots and
lots of historical data,
we do believe we do
know a couple of things.
We know its variance.
The standard deviation was 10.
So let's just assume that we
know the standard deviation.
And we also know--
the second thing
is that the thickness of these
parts is normally distributed.
Those are our
starting assumptions.
our a priori assumptions.
Now what we do is we go, and we
draw 50 different random parts
with the IID assumption.
And we calculate the average
thickness from those.
And I'll tell you,
of those n equals
50 samples, the
actual sample mean
that comes out from that one
sample of size 50 is 113.5.
There you go.
You're blessed with
that piece of data.
Now the first question here,
based on what we've seen,
is what is the distribution
of the mean of the thickness?
What is the PDF
associated with t bar?
Everybody should know this.
What's t bar distributed as?
AUDIENCE: It's normal.
PROFESSOR: It's normal, right.
AUDIENCE: Centered
around the mean.
PROFESSOR: Centered
around the mean, so it
would have the same mu unknown.
And what would its variance be?
AUDIENCE: 2.
PROFESSOR: 2, very good.
So it has the same mean, and
the variance scales as 1 over n.
So we had 50 samples, so
the variance goes down
by that factor.
One quick notation
point here is when
we use this notation of normal
with mu and sigma squared,
I try to be very consistent and
put the mean and the variance
in there.
You will sometimes
find different texts
and different
writers or whatever
putting the mean and
the standard deviation.
So you always want to confirm
that, because one's a square,
and one's the square
root of the other.
So be a little bit careful--
a little bit careful on that.
I try to be consistent and
have that be the variance.
So that was a first
easy question.
We know that based
on sampling theory.
We know the distribution
function for the sample mean.
Now the key question
is, how do we
use that to reason about
the actual population mean?
Well, it's really easy
already-- the best guess.
But the more subtle question
that we've been talking about
is, where do we think the
true mean of the population
lies based on this
one observation?
What range do we think
the true mean has
with some degree of confidence?
Do you think it's plus or
minus 2 around that mean?
minus 20 around that mean?
If I were to ask you to bet your
life on what the true mean is,
you would want to be able to say
with some degree of confidence,
it's actually within
this amount of distance.
I have to say one more
thing, because if I
said it's within some
amount of distance of that,
well, with non-zero
probability, that thickness
could take on values all the
way from plus infinity, if it's
truly normally distributed,
all the way to not quite
negative infinity, because
this is a thickness to 0.
So it's still an
approximate model.
So if I just asked
you, bet your life.
Tell me where you
think the true mean is,
if you wanted 100% chance of
saving your life, you'd say,
it could be anything.
So I have to give
you, when we're
talking about confidence
intervals, another piece
of bounding information.
I want the range.
How far away from that one
observation of the mean
do I need to be with
some probability?
95% confidence or
95% of the time,
where do we think the
true mean would lie?
What that means is if I were
to go and calculate another 50
samples and calculate
the mean, again, we
have that distribution.
And what we're looking for
is that 95% central region
of the PDF associated
with x bar, which
is where 95% of the time, the
mean is actually going to lie.
So that gets us pictorially
and formulaically here
to this notion of the
confidence interval
and how we actually go
about calculating that.
What we're asking-- what
we've got in this situation
is the variance is
known, so I'm not
trying to estimate the variance.
I'm just trying to
reason about the mean.
And I want to estimate it to
some percent, some confidence
interval.
You always have this
chance of being wrong
when you talk
confidence intervals.
You've got some
alpha probability
that the true meaning is
even further away than you
think in your interval.
But you're trying to
quantify that and bound that.
So we typically talk about,
say, an alpha of 5% or maybe 1%
probability of being
outside of your interval.
So there's this
alpha probability
of error associated with
any confidence interval.
So that's that second piece
of data I had to give you.
The first is we want to know
this range-- what the size is.
So the way this works is
we're wanting to know,
based on our calculated
x bar from our sample
of size n, where the
true mean actually lies.
So we know what
we're doing is saying
that the true mean, mu, is
going to be bounded on the left
by the x bar, but then
going some portion
of the distribution to
the left and some portion
of the distribution to the right
until we get the 1 minus alpha.
So this area in here is the
1 minus alpha-- the 95%, say,
central component of
that distribution.
And then we're evenly spreading
the error part, the alpha,
into 2 alpha over
2's on each side,
saying I've got for a
95% confidence interval,
a 2.5% chance that the true
mean is a little bit further off
to the left and a 2.5% chance
that it's a little further
off to the right.
I guess in this picture here
I'm doing an 80% confidence
interval with a total alpha
error risk, error probability,
of 0.2.
And so the question
then becomes,
how far do I have to go out?
And we know that from the
basic probability manipulations
from a normal
distribution you guys
have been dealing with already.
The whole question is, how
many unit standard deviations
of a unit normal
do I have to go?
How many z's out do I have to
go until I have exactly alpha
over 2 out here in the tail?
So for example,
we might know what
this is going to do
is I've got to go out
1.28 standard
deviations to the left
in order to be able to
have just that alpha over 2
to the left of that tail,
and similarly to the right.
Now, notice that we're
also unnormalizing.
The z is the normal--
how many z's you get to,
out of the unit Gaussian,
the probability
out in the tails.
But what we wanted to do is
reason about the location
of the true population.
We want to know the
true population mean.
And so we have to do a little
bit of unnormalization and say,
z alpha gave me the
number of unit normals.
Now, in terms of my
actual population variance
or population
standard deviation,
what does that correspond to?
And this is where the sample
size also comes into play.
We were reasoning about
the distribution associated
with a x bar.
And the x bar is scaled.
It shrunk by that
square root of n
in terms of the
standard deviation.
So when I expand it back
out, I'm counting number of--
first off, together, this is
number of standard deviations
in my x bar.
And then when I
expand that further
out to the number of standard
deviations in my population,
I have to divide back
out by that root n.
So what we've got is
the rationale for being
able to use the PDF associated
with x bar calculate,
probabilities off
of the details,
and get finally to this nice--
this is my fast way
to erase everything--
get back to my nice distribution
here or a nice formula, which
you'll see in Montgomery, you'll
see in all of the textbooks.
It's a wonderful note to have
on your one page set of notes
or cheat sheet
for taking quizzes
in this class and elsewhere.
This is the interval, the
confidence interval formula,
for the location of
the true mean when
the variance was known.
So any questions on that?
We actually want to
return to our example
and see what numbers pop
out because I want to know--
we knew x bar was 113.5.
But I actually want to know,
what is the 95% confidence
interval for that?
And so we can simply go
back to our second question.
Use the fact that we had--
you guys told me what the
distribution was of t bar
was our unknown mu.
And the variance was
scaled, 100 over 50.
So now for a 95%
confidence interval,
what is the true mean?
So I've pictured it here.
And what we're
saying is we want--
we've got this red
curve which, again,
goes with this PDF
associated with t bar.
And I want the plus/minus
z alpha over 2, the alpha
being 0.05.
That's my probability
of being wrong to get
to a 0.95 confidence interval.
So how many z's do I have to go
out to have 95% in the center?
We actually showed
some examples.
If you remember,
last time we looked
at plus/minus 1 sigma,
plus/minus 2 sigma,
plus/minus 3 sigma
for a Gaussian.
And it's actually a very
close approximation.
That plus/minus 2 sigma
is 95% of a distribution.
That's a good rule
of thumb to remember.
It's actually 1.96, not quite 2.
But about plus/minus
2 sigma has 95%.
So you'll often see 95%
confidence intervals
graphically shown.
So we need about 1.96
standard deviations.
Now that translates to
a confidence interval
that tells us, as
a function of n,
the distribution for where
we think the true population
is, based on the sample
size that we had.
The compression that we
got because of sampling
gets us that tighter
standard deviation.
And I've got a symmetric
plus/minus 2.77
for my 95% confidence interval.
Now, notice that all
you had to do here
was be told what the
actual calculated t bar was
and what the
underlying variance was
and the size of your sample.
I didn't even have
to actually give you
a list of all those
values, right?
But I did have to tell
you the sample size.
If sample size changed, that
PDF would narrow or widen,
and your confidence interval
would narrow or widen, right?
So any questions to
where we are now?
It's all seeming pretty clear?
So this is the
relatively easy part
because it's dealing with
normal distributions.
This notion of sampling
is a little bit subtle
because there is
a different PDF,
and you got to know how that
scales with the sample size.
Now I'm going to throw a
few different curves at you,
the different curves being
different probability
distribution functions
than normal distributions.
And I'm going to briefly
cover three of them,
and all three of them
are ones that we actually
will be using in
multiple scenarios
in statistical analysis
and statistical techniques
and tools that we're using.
The first one is a
relatively easy step,
and that's to look at the
student t distribution.
I'll come back to this.
But basically, if we go back
to the example I gave you.
I said, we assumed we knew,
based on, I don't know,
lots of past history what
the underlying variance was
on the thickness of our parts.
What if you don't know that?
What if you have to
estimate that, too?
Well, if you had to
estimate it, you'd
probably use sample standard
deviation, that formula,
and come up with an estimate.
It turns out when you do that,
that additional uncertainty
on what the
underlying variance is
means that the right
distribution for arguing
about the mean when you didn't
know the underlying variance
is no longer a
normal distribution.
It's actually a t-distribution,
and we'll talk about that.
It's a slightly different--
it's very close to
or looks qualitatively close
to a normal distribution,
but we do want to cover that.
And then more have to
do with not the mean,
but arguing about the variance.
If I calculate sample
variance from a distribution,
I calculate s squared using the
formula for a sample of size
50, I get a number.
I do that lots
and lots of times.
I trace out a PDF.
The PDF associated
with the values
of sample variance
calculated from that sample
is a chi-squared distribution.
So we'll talk about what
that shape looks like.
And then we've got a
variance that we've
calculated from a sample.
And a very strange distribution
is the F distribution,
which is the distribution
of the ratio of two normally
distributed variances or two
variances drawn from normally
distributed sample data.
Good heavens.
Why would you ever
be calculating
ratios of variances?
What a weird distribution.
Why would you ever calculate
ratios of variances?
Where might that come up?
There's at least a couple
of cases-- one that's
kind of subtle, but one
that's pretty obvious.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's you're thinking
about the variation of the
actual population, which
varies from your sample.
PROFESSOR: Certainly,
the variance
associated with a
sample of smaller
size than your true population.
So that's exactly true.
That's one important area.
The fact of sample size
entering into spread and things
is very important.
That actually will come up
more in the chi-squared.
But I think a second
very obvious place is
I make a change to a process.
And I'm maybe not trying
to mean center it.
I'm trying to get a
reduced variance process.
I want to know, is this
process better or not?
Is its variance smaller?
So the ratio of
those two variances
are something I might be
very, very interested in.
I want to look at
those and see, well,
I did get a smaller variance.
It's half as small.
Do I have confidence that
the true population variance
is really smaller or not?
And so that's where
the F distribution
is going to come into play.
So we want to be able
to manipulate and deal
with that one as well.
Let me do the student
t-distribution first.
Actually, I can't do that.
Let me do the chi-squared
distribution first.
For the formal
definition of the t,
I need the chi-squared,
even though conceptually,
it doesn't really matter.
So let's talk about the
chi-squared distribution first.
If I start out with truly
normally distributed data
and unit normal,
mean 0, variance 1.
And now, I take a sum
of n of these unit
normals, each one
of which is squared.
So each x sub i is
normally distributed.
I do this weird operation
where I take that sample.
I square it, I take another
draw or another random variable,
also from the same distribution,
square that, and then take
the sum of n of those squared
random variables to create
a new random variable y.
y is the sum of squared unit
normal random variables.
Then I get this
chi-squared distribution.
The distribution of this
new random variable y
is chi-squared with
n degrees of freedom.
Good heavens, what a
weird thing to be doing.
Why would you be taking
random variables,
squaring them, and
taking sums of them?
Well, think back to the formula.
Let's see if I can do this.
What page is that?
Anybody got it there?
8?
There we go, page 5.
Look back at this formula for
sample standard deviation.
First off, I'm subtracting
the mean off of some sample.
So now I've got a
0 mean variable.
Now I'm taking squares of them.
Well, that sounds kind of
like this squaring operation.
And then I'm taking
a big sum of them.
That sounds a lot like
this operation I was just
describing for chi-squared.
So this creation of a new random
variable, this F squared here,
is very closely related to--
that didn't work.
There we go-- very
closely related
to the definition
of chi-squared.
Now the chi-squared,
the PDF associated
with the chi-squared,
looks kind of funky.
It's clearly not normally
distributed, right?
It's kind of skewed.
Notice it's got a
long tail out here
to the right for large values.
Because it's a sum of squared
values, it can't be negative.
So it's truncated.
There's nothing-- can't
be smaller than 0.
Another really weird thing is
that the maximal probability
value is not equal to the
mean of the distribution.
That's kind of interesting.
And there's another
really interesting fact
that is truly useful
and occasionally
comes up on problem sets
and that sort of thing.
The mean, the expected value
of the chi-squared distribution
with degrees of freedom n, is n.
So as I have larger
numbers of variables,
the sum of that larger
number keeps getting bigger.
So that makes sense
when you think about it.
So the point here
is when we actually
do that calculation of a sample
standard or a sample variance
or a sample standard
deviation, the PDF
associated with that
is actually related
to this chi-squared
distribution.
Now there were some
other constants in there.
They're scaling factors.
So for example, we did
a mean shift x bar,
but we didn't normalize
to the true variance,
because we didn't know it.
So there is this relationship
or a scaling factor
before we get to the
chi-squared distribution.
We also had this other n minus
1 factor back on the calculation
of the sample--
sample standard or
sample variance.
So we have to do a little bit
of moving variables around
to get to a chi-squared
distribution.
Another important
point is that the--
let me clean up some of this--
is that the sample
variance is actually
related to a chi-squared with
n minus 1 degrees of freedom.
And I really don't want to
go into a whole discussion
of degrees of freedom because
it's a little bit subtle.
But this reminds
me of another point
that I didn't make
back on slide 8.
Get me to 8, please.
There we go.
Oops, not 48, 8.
Oh, it wasn't 8.
Where was it?
4, 5.
There we go.
Back here on this, notice that
when we calculate sample mean,
we used 1 over n.
But when we calculate
sample variance,
we always use 1 over n minus 1.
Why do we do that?
It turns out that if you need
or want an unbiased estimator
for a sample variance, you need
to divide by 1 over n minus 1
or divide by n minus 1, not n.
Now, as n gets very
large, the difference
doesn't really matter.
But you can go through
some statistical proofs
to show that the best unbiased
estimator needs that n minus 1.
Now the other thing that's
going on in this formula
is we were subtracting
off the mean.
And in this case, we were
also estimating the mean.
So we're using up
essentially one degree
of freedom out of our data
to calculate the sample mean,
leaving us only n minus
1 degrees of freedom
really in the remaining data to
allow variance around the mean.
So I'm not going to go
into much more detail,
other than to simply say the
fact is, when we're calculating
sample standard deviation,
we're actually calculating
two random variables or two
statistics, x bar and variance.
And so you would
need-- you essentially
don't have complete independence
between those two things.
You use up one degree of
freedom for one of those.
Let's use this.
Before we use this, just to
give you a qualitative feel,
here's--
again, plotted a few different
chi-squared distributions.
When n is very small,
it becomes very skewed.
It's quite interesting.
Again, the mean you can see
for n equals 3 here is 3.
It's this blue curve.
And as n increases,
the distribution
shifts to the right.
The mean shift to the right.
But it also spreads out,
which kind of makes sense.
If I've got more and
more random variables,
and I'm looking at the
variance and estimating
that sum of random
variables, its spread
is going to get large.
And another observation is that
as n gets larger and larger,
this also trends towards
a normal distribution,
which for very large n
can be a useful fact.
I want to actually
go in and use--
not that one-- use this
chi-squared distribution
to ask another question
on that thickness example.
I'd actually want
to know, what's
the best guess for the variance
of my thickness of parts?
And better than that, what's a
confidence interval for where
I think the true variance
lies, based on just this one
number for sample variance,
based on my sample of size n
equals 50.
And this is where we do the same
kind of a formula for the range
where we think the
true variance lies,
based on our observation from
one sample of sample standard
deviation.
And this is using
that relationship
between the chi-squared
distribution and F
squared and the true
underlying variance.
So if you go back to
one of those formulas,
what I did was took--
sigma squared was
lying out here.
I moved it up here and divided
the chi-squared down here.
So this is essentially
right in here
that equivalence that we said
before about how F squared was
distributed as a
chi-squared with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom.
So what we've got is a bound--
let me get rid of
all this gook--
a bound, upper and lower
bound, on where we think,
again, the true variance is,
based on our calculated F
squareds.
And what we're doing again is
putting some alpha probability
of being wrong in
each of the tails.
I want the central part.
I want the 95% central
part of where we
think the true variance lies.
Now an interesting point here
is chi-squared is asymmetric.
So if you ever see somebody
going off and writing,
I think the true
variance is equal to F
squared plus or minus
14.2, that should
be a great, big red flag.
It's somebody who doesn't know
what they're talking about.
Well, maybe they have
a huge sample size,
and they're appealing to
a normal distribution.
But what they're probably doing
here is something very wrong.
Because the chi-squared
distribution is not symmetric,
I have my best point
estimate of F squared.
And then I'm going to
go a different distance
to the left and a different
distance to the right.
So here's, still for
our same example,
the chi-squared distribution
for n, a sample size of 50.
So this is a chi-squared
with 49 degrees of freedom.
And again, I want
2.5% in the left tail
and 2.5% in the right tail.
And so if I apply that
formula, and I have to look up
chi-squared with 0.025
and 49 degrees of freedom,
and then the chi-squared
where I need to know--
I want 97.5, everything,
leaving except just alpha over 2
out to the right.
The s squareds are the
same in both cases.
My n minus 1 is the same.
But because these values, the
chi-squareds, are not equal--
whoops.
I guess I got these flipped.
Actually, when you
look at the tables
at the back of Montgomery
or Mayo and Spanos,
be careful on the definition.
They often show
you a little plot
that looks a lot like this.
And they shade in what
their percentage points are.
And sometimes they go from the
right, sometimes from the left.
But the point was
when you actually
look that up, you
get different values
for the left and the right.
And when you divide those
out, you get a range--
get that out of the way.
You get a range finally for
where your true variance lies.
AUDIENCE: So is that through
a [INAUDIBLE] or estimates
of variance or from chi-square
distribution, or is that--
PROFESSOR: The point
is that all estimates--
well, it's strictly true if I'm
drawing from a population that
is normally distributed.
But an approximation
is no matter
what, any time I'm
calculating a variance,
the variance tends to be
chi-squared distributed.
So it's always going
to be these kinds
of chi-squared calculations.
So it's not that the
chi-squared was a special case.
It's the PDF that
you should always
associate it with s squared.
And notice here, we had 102.3.
That's our best guess.
And we had 71.4 and 158.1
for the range and variance.
I always find this a
little bit shocking.
A sample size of 50?
I took 50 samples, right?
And I had-- my underlying
variance, I guess, was 100.
But I took a lot of samples.
And it always shocks
me a little bit
how big the range is on
the estimate of variance
coming out of this.
Here, my estimate of
variance is 102.3.
Well, that's at
least reassuring,
because that's close to the
example that I gave here,
where a priori, I
thought it was 100.
I just basically
popped that out.
What's shocking is
I can go down to 71.
That's like 30% lower than that,
or 158, which is 68% higher
than my point estimate.
And a really important thing
just to know qualitatively
is that estimating a
mean is pretty easy.
And actually, as
sample size grows,
you can get pretty good
tight estimates of mean.
But the estimates of
variance are hard.
You need a lot of
data to estimate
that second-order statistic.
And so we get big
spreads in variance.
So you've got to be really
careful in your reasoning
about variances.
And that'll bring us back to the
F-statistic a little bit later.
So let me go back now to
the student t-distribution.
And it has a formula
and a formal definition
here, which is if I start out
with a random variable z, that
is the unit normal.
And then I divide it by
a random variable that
is chi-squared with k degrees
of freedom, divided by k,
I get a new distribution,
a new variable t,
that is a t-distribution
with k degrees of freedom.
And it's the same question.
My god, why would you
do such a cruel thing
to a random variable-- divide
it by a chi-squared random
variable and some constant k?
And the answer is
that's essentially
what we're doing when
we are normalizing data
like this, when
instead of normalizing
to the true
underlying population
variance or the true
underlying sample variance,
I'm also having to
estimate not only the mean,
but also estimate the
population standard deviation.
We already said, what is s?
s squared is
chi-squared distributed.
So s is a square root of a
chi-squared distribution.
So buried in this
unit normalization
that we like to do to get to
a probability distribution
function-- we can
talk about confidence
intervals on the mean.
We subtract off some
mean, and then we
normalize to s over root n.
But s itself is
this chi-squared.
So it's really closely
related to the operations
that we do when we are
normalizing our sample data,
when we also had to estimate
the standard deviation.
So the way to think
about the t-distribution
is it's really close to
the normal distribution,
except it's perturbed
a little bit,
because we didn't really
know the underlying variance.
We're having to
estimate it also.
So here's some
pictures, some examples.
The red is the unit
normal distribution.
And now for different sizes of
sample, so for an n equals 3,
you have this little
blue distribution.
That's the t-distribution
with degrees of freedom 3.
Notice that it's
a little bit wider
than the normal distribution,
reflecting a little bit
less certainty on
really the location
of that random variable.
Now as n gets
bigger, so we've got
an n equals 10 example
in here in the green,
the chi-square-- or
the t-distribution
gets a little bit tighter.
And for n equals 100, it's
basically almost lying right
on top of the
normal distribution.
So what the t is reflecting is
a little additional uncertainty
because we didn't
know sigma squared.
I had to calculate s squared
from that same sample
distribution.
So that's all that's
really going on there.
If we then say, OK,
I want to get back
to a confidence interval.
But now, I don't
know the variance,
and I have to estimate
that also from my data.
We have essentially the same
confidence interval formula,
the only difference
being instead of z
related to the unit
normal distribution,
we have numbers of
standard deviations
on the t-distribution
that we're arguing about,
again, reflecting that that
t is a little bit wider.
But it's essentially
exactly the same thinking,
just recognizing that now, the
sampling distribution for x
bar when variance is unknown--
is not a normal.
It's a t-distribution.
But all the other operations
are exactly the same.
We look for what alpha error
we're willing to accept,
what our chance of being wrong
on our bounding of the interval
is, and then allocating that
to the left and the right;
figuring out how many
units normal over we
go on not the underlying
population distribution,
but our sampling distribution.
So we still get the benefits of
increasing n getting tighter.
But we just do that all
on the t-distribution.
AUDIENCE: So this is-- will
be necessary for small sample
sizes.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So the point or the
question was this
is only necessary for
small sample sizes.
And that's exactly right
because of the effect
that we see back with the
t-distribution getting
very close in approximation to
the normal distribution for n
becoming appreciable.
I've heard different
kinds of rules of thumb.
Some people like to
say for n about 25,
you're pretty close to
a normal distribution.
Some people like to
draw it at n equals 40.
It really depends on what
kind of accuracy you're after.
But you can be substantially
wrong for very small sample
sizes-- of sample size 5,
which is a natural sample
size you would often use in
some manufacturing scenarios.
So you do have to be
aware for very small n
to use the t-distribution.
This was an example
where we had n equals 50
in our part thickness example.
Let's see how different
things pop out
if we use the t-distribution
or the normal distribution.
So let's go back to our example.
But now, let's say we don't
know either the variance
or the mean.
Both of them are unknown.
We already calculated
the sample mean.
We had 113.5.
And now I'll tell you--
I guess I already gave you
this number previously.
But I'll tell you that we
apply the sample variance
formula to the data, and
out pops the number 102.3.
So again, that's
your best estimate
of the sample variance.
So these are your
point estimates.
But now, I want to go back
to the question, where's
the confidence interval on where
we think the true mean would
be 95% of the time?
Well, now we have to
use the t-distribution.
When we do that with
49 degrees of freedom,
again, k minus 1, because we're
using up 1 for calculation
of the sample mean.
Now we have this slightly
different formula.
Here, we can use the plus/minus,
because the t-distribution,
like the normal
distribution, is symmetric.
So I've got plus or minus
some number of unit, z's.
In this case, it's
unit t's because
the operative distribution
is the t-distribution.
I plug that in.
Notice that for 2.5%
in each of the tail,
the t-distribution
is slightly wider.
Remember, back with
the unit normal,
we said 1.96 plus or minus
standard deviations is 95%.
For the t, you got to go
a little bit further--
2.01.
Not a big difference--
And when you come
out with that, you
get a slightly wider
confidence interval.
I'm less confident.
I got to go further to get to
my 95% confidence on the range
because I'm also estimating.
So in this case, the difference
is pretty much negligible.
And if I had a
sample of size 50,
I would probably just use
the normal distribution.
And that's a good example,
showing that difference
is 5 parts out of 200.
It's really quite small.
One more distribution
I want to mention--
we're not going to
use it much here.
I think I've already
described it briefly--
is this F distribution.
And this arises if I have
one random variable that
is chi-squared distributed.
I take another random variable
that's chi-squared distributed.
And I form a new
random variable R
that is the ratio of
those two, each normalized
to the degrees of freedom
or the number of variables
that went into each of those
chi-squared distributed
variables.
And that is an F with u
and v degrees of freedom.
Again, this comes up when we're
looking at things like ratios
and want to reason about ratios
of true population variances,
based on observations
of sample variances.
And the key place where that
might come up that I mentioned
is experimental design cases.
So this is an injection
molding example,
where you might be looking
at two different process
conditions-- a low hold
time and a high hold time.
And there may be other
things varying, maybe even
other variables varying, that
cause there to be a spread.
Or there's just
natural variation
in the two populations.
And you might ask
questions like,
are these two
variances different?
Did I improve the variance with
that process condition change?
Maybe-- maybe not.
Certainly not obvious
here, so you might
have a very low confidence.
So we're going to go and
use the F distribution
a little bit later when we
do analysis of experiments,
especially where you're looking
to try to make inferences
about whether there
is differences
between a couple of populations.
And again, because we're
dealing with variances,
there's a huge spread
that arise naturally
in these distributions,
purely by chance.
This is a good place
to re-emphasize
that a lot of what's going
on here in random sampling
is they're spread in the
observations that you get.
So here's a very simple
numerical example.
If I start with a variable
that is unit normal,
and I'm just going to take
two samples, sets of size n
equals 20.
So I'm taking two
different samples,
same underlying population.
I'm not making a
process change, say.
I'm just taking two
samples, each of size 20.
By chance, when I take
that first sample size,
I calculate a particular
sample variance, s squared.
And by chance, I
calculate another one
for the second sample.
And if I form the ratio of
those two, what typical range am
I going to observe in the
ratio of those two variances?
For example, what
ratio might I observe
95% of the time or what range?
And that's the F distribution.
In fact, if I look at
the upper and lower
bound on the range of that
ratio for a 95% confidence
interval for this ratio
of two samples of size 20,
I can go anywhere from
2.5 to 0.4 in that ratio.
That's with samples of size 20.
That's a huge range, right?
Imagine, 2 and 1/2 times
bigger variance over here,
compared to over here.
And that occurs
purely by chance.
So in 95% of the time, I
might have ratios within that.
But 5% of the time,
I'll even observe
ratios that are
bigger or even smaller
than those extremo points.
So you've got to be really
careful in reasoning
about variances.
So we're mostly there.
The last thing I
want to do here is
draw the relationship of some
of these two hypotheses tests.
And that gets us very close to
some of the Shewhart hypotheses
that are the basis
for control charts
that we'll talk about
in the next lecture.
But I do want to get the
basic idea in the last five,
10 minutes on what
statistical hypothesis is
and how that relates to some
of these confidence intervals
that we've been talking about.
So the basic idea we've been
doing with these means is
we've been hypothesizing that
the mean has some distribution,
say a normal distribution.
And then when we talked about
this confidence interval,
I would say, accept or
reject the hypothesis
that the mean was within some
range with some probability.
We can extend that to
asking other questions
or other hypotheses,
and then looking
at the probabilities
associated with it,
and saying, with some
degree of confidence,
I believe the hypothesis.
Or I have enough
evidence to counter it.
And a typical example
might be a null hypothesis,
often referred to as H0,
that the mean is some
a priori mean, some phi 0.
The null hypothesis is based
on this sample, this sample
that I'm drawing
from the population.
I have this
alternative hypothesis
that the mean has changed.
It's no longer the same mean.
Do I have enough evidence to say
with some degree of confidence
that the mean has changed?
And it's a little
tricky because there's
all these probabilities
associated
with random sampling.
So I observe a particular
value with some deviation.
How do I know to what
degree there's actual shift,
say, in the mean or not?
So let's look at this.
What we do is we
form the hypothesis.
We then look at the
probabilities associated
with the two cases, and then
based on those probabilities,
say with some degree
of confidence,
I choose one or the other.
And what's important is there's
always the chance of being
wrong, making an error--
those alpha errors out in
the tails, for example--
with that decision.
So that's where this
confidence level comes in.
So let's say we're
looking at this test.
We're asking-- the
null hypothesis
is I have a normal distribution
with some a priori mean
and some a priori variance.
I'm going to draw a new sample.
And based on that, I
want to either decide
that a shift has occurred
or that the data--
or not-- that the data comes
from that distribution or not.
And so what we're
going to do is use
essentially this same
confidence interval idea
and say, say to 95%
confidence, 95% of the time,
if my value lies in the central
part of that distribution,
I'm going to accept the--
well, in this case,
the null hypothesis
that my new sample still comes
from that same distribution.
So that would be my 95%,
my 1 minus alpha, if alpha
is a 5% error.
But if I observe a
sample mean, say,
or I observe a piece of
data that lies out here,
I'm going to reject
the null hypothesis.
I'm going to say
instead, I think
I've got an unlikely
event by chance
that I think instead indicates
something has changed.
Something has changed
in the process.
And we'll call that the
region of rejection.
So again, already you
can see one kind of error
that's likely to pop up.
There is a confidence
interval, this alpha.
There is a significance
level to the test,
very similar to the
confidence interval
idea and the alpha error
associated with that.
So right away, you see
there's one kind of error--
it's referred to
as a type I error--
on these kinds of
hypothesis tests.
We're rejecting the
null hypothesis out
here in the tails with
some probability alpha.
If I observed a point
out there in the tails,
even if that population
or that distribution
is still operative,
it is, in fact, true.
My samples are still coming
from that distribution.
But I happened to draw a
sample way out in the tail.
And I said, well,
that was unlikely.
That was unlikely
in this picture.
I'm rejecting the
null hypothesis.
I'm claiming this is evidence
that something changed
when, in fact, nothing changed.
I just got unlucky, right?
So the first type of
error that you can make
is this type I error.
It's also sometimes referred
to as producer error,
producer risk.
You're the manufacturer.
You reject your
part because your--
or you reject a batch,
say, because your sample
was way out here in the tail.
You're taking the risk of
rejecting and throwing away
good product, even though
it really was good.
If I took more samples, it would
go back and really indicate
what was going on--
that the product was still good.
So it's also sometimes
referred to as producer risk.
But there's another
possible error.
There is an error associated
with the distribution shifted
or changed.
I still accepted it
based on a random sample
from the different
distribution that
happened to fall in
my other distribution.
And that's referred
to as type II error--
has a probability associated
with that called beta.
We've been talking all
about these alphas.
Well, there's also a beta.
It's also sometimes referred
to as a consumers' risk.
The manufacturer did
a little inspection.
The mean happened to fall
in the region of acceptance.
He shipped it.
Turns out, it was actually
by bad chance just happened
to fall in the good region.
It really is coming
from a bad distribution.
So let's look at that.
What is this beta?
Well, for the type II
errors, we essentially
have to hypothesize a shift of
some size, some little delta.
And then we assess
the probabilities
that I'm drawing from the tail
of that shifted distribution
and just happen
to fall over here
in this region of acceptance
for our good distribution.
So this is the
probability associated
with our null hypothesis.
This is our starting
distribution.
Our alternative
hypothesis here is
that I had a plus delta
shift in the mean.
So this is our
possible new operative.
And in fact, for
a type II error,
this is actually at work.
Remember, this is the
region of acceptance.
So I'm claiming this is good.
But if the population
actually shifted over there
to the right, notice
off on the left
here we've got this
whole tail, where
if I drew from the
shifted distribution,
I've got that tail, that lightly
shaded blue tail, falling
in the region of acceptance,
where I would say it's
a good distribution
and erroneously except.
And one can simply apply the
same probabilities to basically
go in and calculate--
just integrate up and do the
cumulative normal distribution
function to calculate
what that tail is.
So it's all the
same probabilities.
So the applications of this
are really going to be on--
of hypothesis testing.
This would be
shifts of the mean.
You can start to see worrying
about monitoring your process
and seeing if something
changed in your process,
a shift occurred, and
being able to detect that.
And that gets us
to control charting
that we'll do next time.
So this is all pretty
much the same stuff.
And now this is a peek ahead.
You'll see process control.
And we'll talk about
repeated samples
in time coming from the
same distribution next time.
So we will see you on Thursday.
And we will dive into
Shewhart control charts.